haben sie freiwillig zugenommen also
oder war das meer so freiwillig so viel
gegessen waffeln heute gadgets fürs
handy
ob ihr einfach also sachen mit denen man
die handy erfahrung ein bisschen
interessanter gestalten kann basteln sie
auch manchmal
ich war die tagen im kindergarten wir
haben so schön gewickelt was trägt ein
prickelndes erlebnis
super ich an wie kann gerne dass uns
noch alleine sagen weil dann haben sie
auch ein paar gags
es ist ein flop socket müssen sie das
pocket im sinne von socken
ich glaube in keiner sprache als zocken
aber zuerst nehmen wir einen saugnapf
gegen den auf papier und zeichnen mit
dem bleistift darum damit wir dann eine
passende form und größe haben um das zu
dekorieren
sie sind ja extrem jungen aber jetzt
politisch gesprochen im nicht lauter
werden sie wahrscheinlich jetzt schon
tot
aber im schnitt im plus
wir können das auch auswahl meist noch
aus gern genommen sie dürfen sich eine
farbe auch sache aber die sind gegen die
burka stimmt verstimmt weil ich gerne
frauen wie männern in die augen und ins
gesicht schauen welche beide mitbürger
setzen wir ein bisschen blöd oder aber
einfacher wenn es nicht gekommen wären
hätten wir gegen jemand anderen
ok dann können wir das jetzt
ausschneiden sie gelten ja aus
merkel-kritiker oder sie sind mehr warum
denn eigentlich der weil sie halt nicht
einfach nicht sagen also ich finde ja
demokratie und auch eine gute diskussion
gibt dass man dass man unterschiedlicher
meinung ist dass man gute argumente
austauschen also meine kiste hier oben
jedenfalls springt immer nur an wenn sie
mal ein paar andere argumente und
sichtweisen ins spiel kommen und meine
eigene anreise kurz kam auch aus jojo
benutzen wenn man es sich leicht gemacht
- sprich viel schneller und deswegen bin
ich eigentlich ein großer freund von
diskussionen mit diskutiere gerne und
ich finde nicht dass für jede diskussion
gleich immer personal weiter so eine
ganz eklige version von spiderman die
wir nach drehen
für die aussagen
dort tritt ich hab viel gemacht
entspannt ich habe eigentlich nicht wie
gemacht aber sie finden dass dieser sind
und so verletzlich das meer retten das
bin ich morgens ohne make up
jetzt machen wir ein paar lautsprecher
für jede party der kracher dafür
brauchen wir eine papprolle von einem
küchenpapier
ich hab da was vorbereitet sie können
auch die themen die wir schon haben wir
im küchenstudio jetzt können sie so was
sagen wie die rollenverteilung stimmt
wir wollen fünf kassen wollen wir noch
mal ich hab da schon was vorbereitet
kohl die rollenverteilung stimmen
ja wir machen jetzt ein sprecher ok
damit nun doch fürchten muss zum knacken
die man so richtig laufen in deutschland
verkehren dann wieder öfter ja schon
jetzt hören sie denn nicht ich bin
glaube ich öfter zu hören als dass ich
ihn höre ehrlicherweise nicht es war ein
richtiger angeber satz stimmt ja gerne
an die deutschlandfunk klassenerhalt
vielleicht kann dann hören wie oft sie
rüber kommen den angeber oder hier
offensichtlich groß haben sie mich
erwischt wollen wir eigentlich kanzler
werden
wir haben noch mehr gute kanzler wer
nicht kämpft hat sehr dafür dass wir
auch bleibt dass sie eine gute kanzlerin
bleibt kanzlerin bleibt der wahlen in
diesem jahr
das ist als nur die halterung fürs handy
jetzt benutzen wir diese zwei besser um
ich find ja jens spahn ist ein name den
könnte man noch verbessern
er stimmte das problem an dem problem an
dem namen ist jeweils nur eine silbe es
müsse man ja und sparen klingt ein
bisschen so als würde man versuchen
spannend zu sagen und dann fängt man
aber eine super bewährt raum namens spaß
mit meinem nachnamen ich gar keine
probleme
ein problem habe ich auch nicht aber
natürlich habe ich den zweiten vornamen
georg jens g so muss er nur noch ein
paar sekunden auf wenn das gar nicht
funktioniert ein solcher natürlich auch
sehr geeigneten ein viertel von draus
gemacht und ist auf abhörsicher das habe
früher allerdings auch gemacht
die habe ich natürlich eine mal gedacht
die mädchen auf dem land ist in dem
kleinen dorf bei aus das atommülllager
da ist ein zwischenlager für
kernbrennelemente bestimmt haben sie
dabei demonstriert ich war ja in der
anti anzahlung für die vampir weil mir
zu viele leute vorschreiben wollten wir
ich zu denken habe also wie lassen sie
es lieber von atomen beeinflussen als
von menschen nein lass mich gerne von
argumenten beeinflussen von dem man sich
dann für richtig halte nachdem ich die
argumente gehabt
[Musik]
gleich ein bisschen anders klingt schon
denken könnte ich ganz ich entweder
frisch gemacht dann können wir noch den
pop soccer der es mittlerweile abgekühlt
das hält machen zweifel ja sehr gerne
und kann ich nämlich damit angeben wenn
sie mal kanzler sind
ich weiß nicht ich glaube ihr comedy
talent ist eigentlich erstaunlich klein
dafür dass also wenn man mit 15 in die
junge union geht hat man eigentlich ein
leben das auch aus familien dasein
rauslaufen könnte oder das ist
wahrscheinlich schon so aber ich bin
halt kein guter bastler wie man merkt
aber es ist sehr lustig wie coco dann
passte da haben sie die nummer von
angela merkel anrufen
[Musik]